[Musique]
nous sommes au restaurant des Templiers
avec son chef son patron son âme c'est
Jean-Luc Madec pour un nouveau numéro de
de bouche à oreille alors là vous allez
nous parler de quoi de la galette alors
pas tout à fait de la galette on va
commencer par parler du Sarasin alors
pas le Sarasin qui fait la guerre au
croisé mais quand même il trouve que ce
sont les croisés qui un petit peu quand
même puisque en rentrant de croisade euh
les croisés passent par l'Asie en Asie
il découvre une plante tout à fait
extraordinaire extrêmement solide c'est
le Sarasa voilà il la porte euh au
royaume de France là il le plante un peu
partout au fur et à mesure de leur
remontée vers le royaume et puis on
s'aperçoit très vite que cette plante
garde sa solidité beaucoup plus
facilement dans des terres acides que
dans des terres classiques et les
terresci part ben pas vraiment en tout
cas ça ne tient pas et ça ne se
développe pas partout c'est en Bretagne
figurez-vous mon cher Patrice que va se
développer le plus cette plante tout à
fait extraordinaire avec laquelle on
fait de la farine je commence à
réfléchir je vois quelque chose Sarasin
ça n'est pas autre chose que le blé noir
voilà et donc vous imaginez bien qu'il y
a une relation de cause à effet
immédiate entre le développement de
cette culture et les galettes la galette
et le repas principal des Bretons partir
du 13e siècle et ceci jusqu'à
aujourd'hui puisque en fait on fait
cette galette encore maintenant avec une
particularité qu'il faut savoir la
galette n'est cuite que d'un côté pour
garder toute la souplesse pour mettre
pourir mettre ingrédients à l'intérieur
et puis refermer après voilà très
joliment alors au départ la crêpe est
aussi au noir mais elle est cuite des
deux côtés elle est croustillante elle
est fragile difficilement manipulable
donc elle reste quand même un important
on peut pas la rouler on peut pas la on
peut rien faire avec donc il faut
attendre une autre farine avec le blé
c'est la farine blanche c'est grâce au
fr absolument qu'on va développer une
autre forme de crêpe alors là on sort de
la galette pour rentrer dans un
ingrédient beaucoup plus noble on
pourrait dire ça mais en réalité on est
à la fin du 19e ou début du 20e siècle
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus loin alors
qu'on démocratise la farine blanche qui
était inaccessible au peup avant
évidemment et bien sûr d' l'expression
un froment et un dessert voilà Absolum
c'est génial donc voilà si vous allez en
Bretagne ben sachez que c'est grâce aux
croisad que vous mangez c'est délicieux
et on cuit la galette que d'un seul côté
et cuit d'un seul côté très attention la
prochaine fois je regarde voilà merci
beaucoup Jean à bientôt
[Musique]
Patrice